okay so now that you're a little bit  removing a few months removed have you  thought about who you want to encourage  now from your circle to do Dancing with  the Stars I mean I would recruit the  gymnast but Ally's already done it  Lori's already done it maddie is a  little busy with school but she might  want to do it and I don't think Gabby  that's it yeah you know one of the  things I loved about that seasons that I  felt like we saw the growth of Simone I  feel like during the season and like as  time went on I felt like I did grow into  myself a little bit more was there ever  a second date with mr. good yeah I've  been on like one maybe proper date he's  got a good body but that's it I'm just  saying it's I'm just saying  has there been a third and a fourth yes  is this the boyfriend no he's not a  boyfriend yeah it's good he's still a  good guy yes he's still an amazing guy  [Music]